zuschauer schlimmer des fahrens ich bin
ich selber verarbeiten sondern selber in
der handlung kann kann reagieren und als
zuschauer hoffen dass der junge ist
jetzt richtig
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport bot dem
sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers heute zu gast frisch
gebacken olympiasieger zugführer
alessandro hämmerle herzlich willkommen
du bist ja frisch oder zurückgekommen
aus peking mit edelmetall im gepäck ist
eine schöne goldmedaille mitgenommen im
snowboard-cross wie geht es dir jetzt wo
doch schon ein paar tage zurückblicken
kannst du auf den größten erfolg dann
kann ich ja immer noch sehr sehr gut
natürlich einige termine abklappern muss
aber es sind schöne sachen versuch so
wirklich zu genießen
erinnern wir uns ganz kurz zurück an den
finalrennen an das überqueren der
ziellinie die meisten von uns haben ja
daheim hat zugeschaut haben seinen
bruder jubelnde gehört das rennen live
mitverfolgt wie ist es dir gegangen an
dem tag an dem rennen selbst recht
gefühlswelt hast du durch gelebt mag ich
bin eigentlich extrem motiviert aufstand
richtig lust gehabt auf das rennen war
hängig schon mal froh die eine größte
hört überstanden zu haben dass sie sind
am wettkampftag in kommen und wie viel
geschlafen habe und danach für mich
schon 50 prozent davon erledigt er ist
womöglich der weg kam selber natürlich
hat der als tampas müssen und war vom
ersten quali lauf bis dann doch zum
großen finale zum ersten platz war schon
einmal ein breiter weg aber aber eine
tolle aufgabe und wenn hätte es zu
leicht gewesen wäre aber das war nicht
so schön das war ja auch knapp es war
ein gab es einen moment und gesagt dass
jetzt gehört das ding mir oder hasst das
erst wirklich nach der zieleinfahrt
realisiert dass die gold medaille
gemacht hast ja wie in der dritten kurve
vorbeigefahren bin habe ich gedacht
jetzt knapp für verliert und dann eine
wirkliche leben gearbeitet habe über die
letzten willen dass ich noch mal als
letzter aus dem körper heraus holen und
um volle runter arbeit und machte
erstmal wieder weggenommen worden glaube
dadurch zum ziel mit dem windschatten
ist noch mal knapp worden aber die für
mich waren eigentlich sicher nach der
ziellinie das ist habe sicher da standen
zwei hundertstel das reicht doch eine
auf der videoleinwand gesehen habe vom
finale dann war war einmal kurz man
immer sicher weil sie extrem knapp
ausgeschaut hat wo ist insoweit war weil
natürlich sehr erleichtert das gibt
einem durch den kopf in den letzten
metern die letzten welle nichts gesagt
dass man dafür noch mal hinein fährt
wirklich alles gibt nicht locker lässt
und vielleicht schon sicher ist dass es
glaubt oder schon aufgibt soll man
denken dass wir eh nix mehr wie schafft
man das genau in diesen sekunden die
anscheinend wirklich entscheidend waren
für zwei hundertstel differenz voll da
zu sein und wirklich noch einmal das
letzte herauszuholen ja oder ich morgen
gegen mal nicht mehr brennt natürlich
also werde ich mir voll fokussiert und
extrem motiviert da hat man nicht viel
zeit zum nachdenken es kommt element auf
elemente kurze ruhephase war war nach
einer kurzen exit und dann habe ich mir
noch mal motiviert und danach
auf das übliche konzentrieren müssen
dass die saubere linie fahre ich bin
immer so riskant gewesen also bald ein
sprung gewesen ich bin hier geschaut
dass ich lange mache bevor jetzt kurz
kommen geschwindigkeit verliert da war
das einzige taktische waren dabei waren
sowohl die köln hat natürlich vollgas
geben ja schwester bist aber in dem
moment internetseite da habe ich einfach
umfahren marketing und sobald über der
ziellinie ewigkeit über solis achten
auch denke dass auch gesagt da muss man
einfach abrufen wie viel davon ist
automatismus also dass das wirklich ein
gearbeitet hat wie man reagiert in
bestimmten situationen in bestimmten
situationen wie viel davon kann man
wirklich trainieren oder ist das dann
einfach wirklich vom wettkampf dann
abhängig
sich extrem von wettkampf abhängig also
bei uns im sport muss man sagen es kommt
doch so wie es kommt alles kann man
nicht planen und immer versucht es zu
planen wenn ich mir vielleicht nicht so
spontan es muss sehr viel intuitiv
passieren sobald sie aus der hütten
rauszieht da gebe einfach vollgas und
dann muss reagieren was kommt damit die
leute nehmen hier kann man wie gesagt
nichts planen man muss offen sein für
jedes szenario natürlich ist man quasi
wie oft und verschiedenen seit zehn
jahren im kopf durchgefahren ja denn so
wie es gekommen ist hat man sich schon
was ich geplant gehabt wie es vielleicht
sein könnte und nicht mehr froh wenn man
vorbereitet ist für jede situation aber
wie gesagt im vorhinein
beschwerden vor was alles zu planen habe
da verkauft muss ich mehr sondern man
muss vater dann hoffen dass man schon so
wichtiger war dass einen
unsicherheitsfaktor nämlich angesprochen
die anderen kollegen die auf der strecke
sind weiß man natürlich nie was die
machen wie die reagieren und sich das
dann auf dich auswirkt wie ist das bei
euch aus gibt es strecken der einem meer
liegen immer bei denen skisport weiß man
ja den einen liegt die strecke mehr und
dort fühlt er sich wohler ist es bei
euch auch so oder kann man das gar nicht
so sagen doch auf jeden fall ist sagte
malki navarra stecke die mir schon sehr
gut leben ich längere geraden ein
bisschen größere elemente nicht so
extrem drehende kurven es ist alles was
mir so entgegenkommt man sie sagen wenn
es nur drehen dich also nur so 108 180
grad kurven das dogma gernet und kurze
geraden milliardär der gern in der
gerade überholt so wie es auch im finale
gemacht haben und nicht in einer kurve
riskiert in der kurve kann man immer
sehr gut abdecken das nächste im hohen
risikofaktor dabei dass man ein
zweikampf kunden und irgendwas
vielleicht ein ungefähres passiert
moderat zu staus kommen kann der kollege
oder im hintergrund zieht mit ihrem
video dabei ist maria kurzweil auf die
steak fahren also hinten aufs brett aber
zum glück aber jetzt in dem moment merkt
aber die zu jung sind wir sind
eingestürzt
vor dem jahr war es in der ersten der
jungen sicher wichtig dass man vorne weg
fahren kann und das risiko minimiert
jetzt hast du noch ein faktor
angesprochen ja wenn sowas passiert dass
der event darauf fährt und man kriegt
das mit und denkt sich das super was
warum passiert das jetzt wie schafft man
das mental dass man dass man muss das
wahrscheinlich gleich im kopf irgendwie
zur seite legen und darf sich nicht
damit beschäftigen wie unfair das ist
die wickelkommode für in china vor allem
hat man dass sich herr kurven habe ich
nichts sagen führen waren eigentlich
opposition in richtung mit der
entscheidung da habe ich schon sehr dran
klagte die die vergangenen jahre aber es
gibt einfach sachen die kann man nicht
beeinflussen und ich glaube das gibt es
bei jedem im leben und die monsters of
peace geht sie weg steht ja vorne weg
fahren ist natürlich die beste devise
aber das funktionierte aber
also ja schwierig sagt es gibt sachen
die kann man nicht beeinflussen
ja die versuchen wir natürlich zu
ignorieren so gut es geht also auch da
eine gute kopie mechanismus wie mit
solchen situationen umzugehen ich habe
einen bruder schon angesprochen der
selber auch gefahren ist und weiß wie er
sie ist als aktiver sportler all diese
momente durch zu leben wir haben live
kommentaren auch jubeln gehört hast du
dir das angeschaut wie er da einen
zieleinlauf emotional kommentiert hat ja
ich habe sind ziemlich gleich mal sehen
wie wir das kino damit vier wort hat wie
sich alle daheim haben aber extrem ist
aber sicher spezieller relativ
situationen kennt zuschauer schlimmer
wie es fahren sehr schwer wenn ich
selber verarbeiten unserer selber in der
hand und kann kann reagieren und als
zuschauer hoffen dass der junge ist
richtig
da war schon sehr emotional es gesehen
habe was hast du denn von seinem
größeren bruder mitnehmen kann hat er
glaube ich ja 2016 seine karriere
beendet was hast du von ihm lernen kann
jetzt das snowboarden gemeinsam gemacht
genau oder größere bruder hat wie man
ein bisschen dem weg vorgezeigt sei es
für mich als jüngerer bruder bisserl
angenehm da standen damals zu erstehen
sind ein bisserl gefühl kriegt der
forscher die ersten rennen gefahren
wirklich man hat sehr viel lernen können
und hat natürlich immer ein guter
sparringspartner kate vor dem lernen
können hat sind ich glaube das war sehr
entscheidend für die karriere man
bekommt aber natürlich auch die
negativen seiten relativ schnell mit
misserfolg oder wenn es einmal nicht
funktioniert zeigt dass einem da nicht
irgendwie ab man sieht okay beim großen
bruder klappt nicht immer alles nach
wunsch dass man sich dann denkt warum
sollte ich mir das noch antun oder
spannt das dann noch einmal extra nicht
anscheinend hat sehr gut funktioniert
hat ihr also china oder auch sportliche
erfolge feiern können
bestimmt hinten raus leider nach der
flitzer mehr funktioniert für mich war
es aber gut zu sehen weil er sicher arzt
also es gibt auch ein leben neben dem
sport sehr erfüllend und schön ist und
nimmt mal ein bisschen den druck weil er
sagt dass ich nicht alles jetzt auch
nach dem olympiasieg ist natürlich
nochmal spezieller aber
wer sich eine ewige im spiel bleiben
können auch und bin gespannt was danach
kommt das wären auch gleich über
sprechen dass es auch noch ein paar
jahre weiter gehen kann haben wir auch
schon einige deiner kollegen
bewiesen du hast gemeint das nach dem
sport jetzt ein bisschen druck draußen
sie dazu liebt der sieger glaube ich
geht das noch einmal erleichtert dass da
ein bisschen druck weg fällt aber erst
nach einem weiteren bruder nämlich denn
luca der fährt auch er hat sich vor
quali für die olympischen spiele noch
verletzt wie und rasthaus du ihm noch
alles zu erscheinen die snowboardcrosser
gehen einer familie relativ gut ja
lustig dass man dass man alle bei dem
klaren sind wir haben wir drei jungs
sportlerheim für extrem gerne und der
große wurde hat sowieso sofort macht und
uns eigentlich eingefallen ja der look
ist schwierig nach der verletzung muss
man sich wieder vertrauen aber ich
glaube dem der knopf aufgeht ist jede
möglichkeit offen für ergebnisse
bekommen können wie intensiv
berät zu ihnen betreute ried oder
vielleicht auch bewusst zurück was auch
durch schwieriges wenn man wie laut es
ist immer schwierig wie viel wie viel
kann somit geben
es ist doch ein einzelsport am main vom
tag steht er alleine im stark geht und
muss muss den weg alleine dorthin
machten aber
die toom oft schwer zu sagen wie viel de
mails oder nervt ist vielleicht schon
beeinflusst vielleicht auch schon
irgendwie negativ ein letzter zeit
lassen viele
versuche zeigen mehr alleine machen zu
lassen und jeder auf mich zukommen zu
lassen wenn etwas wissen will
natürlich müssen wenn wir was auch
falten ein oder anderen tipp stecken
aber das darf man im team allgemeinen
die recht zum bruder noch ein bisschen
mehr
spezielle verbindung aber ich glaube die
erfahrung muss jeder selbst machen zum
schluss erfolgreich sein zu können das
ging schon einmal sehr weise anscheinend
hast du da in der konstellation auch
viel von seinem bruder michael lernen
kann wie er wahrscheinlich in diesen
situationen mit dir auch umgegangen ist
ja heber das ist ein schock gewesen aber
aber sicher hat jeder ein eigener typ
punkt braucht jeder dass das eigene und
chemie habe den kleinen haus gefunden im
jungen alter das sind nicht alles gleich
machen muss wie wir jetzt andere
kollegen die vielleicht erfolg haben und
ich glaube das ist schon ganz ein
wichtiger faktor im einzelsport dass du
rausfinden was für die gut ist und dann
da wirklich deine linie marsch obwohl
alle anderen waren schon zeigen wenn
alle sagen nach rechts vors tor
vielleicht für die ich habe uns nach
links gehen und das ist das braucht auch
mut und die erfahrung muss man einfach
machen und wenn das natürlich dann
positiv belohnt ist ein gestärkter sein
den eigenen weg zu gehen das kann man
jetzt auf jeden fall sein seine eigene
linie gehen dann eigenen weg wie würdest
du denn deinen weg beschreiben ich würde
sagen schaut der weg von alessandro
hämmerle aus die tabelle stimmt immer so
verbissen wie man sich das vorstellen
könnte also
trainieren bin gibt immer vollgas aber
wenn ich merke jeder körperlich
unterschiedlichen wenn mir alles weh tut
den calibra montag rausnehmen und sagen
mach halt einfach nichts die erholung
ist genauso wie ich dir gehört zum
training genauso dazu und ich habe diese
show ein entscheidender faktor
viele athleten sicher schwert und
speziell in der gruppe zum sagen heute
muss ich mal daheim bleiben und und auf
meinen körper hören wenn er normal
gespielt denn auf dauer krank oder oder
verletzte stehen und dann hat er
schlechte pause wieder eine tag war
einmal raus nimmt also sich ein
balanceakt und ja da muss man auch ein
gefühl gehen als solist dazu klingen
also wenig zu das ist natürlich schade
aber
man muss individuell arbeiten mit
nichtstun wird man glaube ich nicht
erlebt er sich an als hätten wir ganz
ganz viel olympiasieger in österreich
gott sei dank nicht so aber einfach auf
sich hören aufs gefühl hören ist glaube
ich hat das was dich leitet ich werde
mir das auf jeden fall von dir ab
schauen und ein paar mal daheim bleiben
man schauen was man trainer dazu sagt
wie
kommt man vor allem in der ganzen
familie das alles norbert hahn ist das
im montafon einfach automatisch mit
dabei dass man am platz steht oder war
das bei euch ein besonderer weg ja es
munter vorne oder als vorarlberger steht
man gesellschaftliche
denn es eigentlich dazu gekommen dass
der ältere bruder geschenkt bekommen hat
das hat uns dann einfach mehr taugt wir
waren alle ski clubs inne skirennen
gefahren aber
ebenso die die liebe dafür gehabt und
das hat man den mehr als spaß gemacht so
mit meinem freund einfach so wurden
gehen ohne ohne große rennen zu fahren
anfangen wenn die ware im freestyle
bereich es hat mir einfach dauerte bis
die kreativität
habe nebenbei jemand nova training im
skiclub ja schon ja das haben wir immer
mitgemacht und hatte megaspaß brachte in
der gruppe und das war einfach mehr die
frage im vordergrund als wir es jetzt
mal skifahren gehabt habe und das hat
mir extrem motiviert dass ihr die
einzelnen wochenenden und so weiter
damals auch schon investiert habe ihn in
die karriere damals war es einfach
mehrere und habe es nur darum gehen
können am wochenende für mich war das
alles alles toll und lässig auch 50 und
ja und das eine hat dann zum anderen
führt und hat sie zwar da und hat jetzt
wieder da und reden über deine erfolg
aber nicht nur deine erfolge waren im
snowboard da sondern mit benny kahl und
an airgas noch in anderen snowboard
bewerbung sehr erfolgreich gewesen ist
österreich mittlerweile eine etablierte
international erfolgreiche snowboard
nation kann man so sagen spätestens nach
den spielen auf jeden fall so wirklich
in allen disziplinen haben wir gold
metallic macht in pcs ins paradies so
gerne silberring
auf jeden fall die anderen ja sicher
bisher nachsehen gehabt ich spiele ja
bei uns wollen darf so kann das liegen
dass wir da jetzt in allen disziplinen
und eben nicht nur in einer so gut sind
sondern wirklich durch die bank immer
wieder geht medaillen gut sind ja wir
haben gab einfach topmannschaft und
unter betreuung
unterstützt uns auch wirklich sehr sehr
gut ja sehr viele athleten bei uns
müssen speziell im bundesheer durch das
kann man die jugend immer mehr fördern
und es kommt da immer wieder was noch
natürlich haben wir in der topfahrer
überall drinnen die den weg fahrzeugen
die junge auch motivieren und das team
möglich dann auch solche dinge also man
kommt in den strukturen wo alles möglich
ist und das motiviert noch mal
zusätzlich das team auch jetzt immer
wieder hervorgehoben angesprochen wie
kann man sich seinem team vorstellen
also natürlich dann seine kolleginnen
und kollegen mit denen man
wahrscheinlich trainiert und gemeinsam
verhalten ist aber was steckt da alles
dahinter ein apparat an menschen die
verschiedenste aufgaben haben aber wie
kann man sich das vorstellen na ja es
ist so beginnt jetzt sage ich mal bei
uns im frühjahr
ich denke ich dass haupt ihn bei uns im
olympiazentrum bei mir in vorarlberg
aber es besteht da aus coni trainer
physio und dann auch ein herr sport bin
ich da stationiert das ist alles in
einem
legt man mal den grundstein für für die
saison und den bei uns geht es ab
september dann im schnee los als dabei
drei coaches haben wir mittlerweile drei
service laut und immer ein physiker mit
dann mit am start ja die betreiber uns
dem verordnet auf dem schnee und ja das
ist der ganze trainings da ich glaube
ich aber vergessen
wie wird es dann den faktor material bei
euch
bewerten oder erklären ist das so dass
man wirklich mit einem schlecht
präparierte brett chancenlos ist auch
wenn man ein super fahrer ist an einem
tag wo vielleicht ganz normale
bedingungen herrschen die stadt muss man
sich einstellen immer mehr um frau eben
mal kurz geht und der vergleich zur
formel 1 gebracht wenn der mercedes war
so leichter
als top service team brachten extrem
unterschied also wenn ihr mit einem mit
einem schlecht präparierten platz fahren
muss dann nicht spätestens in der
zweiten runde aus also ich leider gottes
unmöglich aber zum glück kommen
topmannschaft und top-service
letzten jahres das ganz ganz selten
passiert wenn man etwas eine basis haben
gut reagieren können und das noch
ausmerzen
von dem her wirklich ein ganz
entscheidender faktor dass man oben
stehen darf wie tief bist du da
involviert mann hatte mal wieder von
technikern und leuten die da wirklich
nächtelang sich selbst mit den skiern
oder mit dem heutigen die befassen ist
das auch etwas was du machst oder eher
nicht so in den vergangenen jahren haben
wir uns schon extrem viel mit dem
snowboard selbst befasst auch bildung
und schule macht extrem viel aus damals
jungen waren hätten tag das ist wirklich
so entscheiden dies sicher und
erfolgsfaktor der vergangenen drei
jahren um die gesamt weltcups nach hause
bringen haben können da haben wir
einiges geändert hat braucht aber sehr
viel erfahrung und auch mit dem team
rund um spezielle richtung entwicklung
von snowboards aber sobald im belag und
was auf dem belag aufkommt gwd 16 wird
diese ab weil das ist noch mal eine
wissenschaft für sich also das machten
das service team und ich sag nur obst
oder nicht man kann auch schon sagen ich
weiß dass so was von dir selber nicht
hörst aber dass du den sport auch in den
letzten jahren sehr geprägt heißt wenn
nicht sogar der weltcup und große
eigenes niveau auch wirklich dominiert
hat und jetzt auch verdient eine
goldmedaille geholt hast drei
gesamtweltcupsiegerin letzten saisonen
das ist glaube ich derzeitige rekord
geteilt und du stehst auch von einem
vierten
gesamtweltcupsieg das erfolgsfaktor
material angesprochen oder das kann ja
nicht die alleinige erklärung sein für
diese beständigkeit auf diesem hohen
niveau über so viele jahre wie würdest
du dir das erklären ja es ist das klingt
schon wie man immer alles so aufgesagt
kriegt in form von rennen zu rennen und
wir probieren immer unser bestes zu
geben material natürlich entscheidender
faktor aber ich glaube dass sie sich die
eine oder andere gute jungs
voraussetzung mitbringen und battle net
so schlecht stehe dass das ist immer so
wissel möglich ist ich habe aber genauso
meine schwächen wie stärker mit gesagt
die kurs führung ist auch entscheidend
für für für die ergebnisse aber glaubt
mir niemand konstanter werden egal was
da steht und das hat einfach aber mit
der ganzen mannschaft zu tun und du hast
einen gewissen fokus ich habe mit dir im
vorgespräch sofort gemerkt
olympiasieg ist ja schön und gut aber es
gibt auch für heuer noch ziele du hast
noch weltcuprennen vor dir und da muss
natürlich noch der vierte gesamtweltcup
sieg in folge her was fehlt dir um das
zu erreichen
momentan ist er ganz knappe kiste
zwischen 1 und 2 also im letzten rennen
waren wir noch ex aequo dann hat er als
trainer gut und ich bin zweiter waren
aber es war auf einem kurs wo man
eigentlich gar nicht zu pflegen ist
jetzt folgt nur ein traum und weser und
alles sind zwei länder und die im
vergangenen jahr gewinnen können die man
sicher von der streckenführung einiges
besser liegen im fokus gilt natürlich
muss man es von rennen zu rennen sehen
natürlich rekord für gesamt
weltcupsieger klingt schon sehr sehr
schön und wie schoss ziel ist natürlich
lästige wenn wir noch eine goldmedaille
nach ziel hat ich glaube ich auch sehr
wichtig für die karriere dass man die
nächsten jahr in der voll dahinter sind
ja und da werden noch mal voll
attackieren das heißt vier gesamt
weltcup siege hintereinander wäre rekord
wieweit möchtest du diesen das wort
ausbauen auf 89 gesamtweltcupsieg
hintereinander bis jetzt 28 man hat
gesehen dass man in einer sportart jetzt
nicht ein limit setzen muss in diesem
alter was hast du dir noch vorgenommen
sportlich ja ich glaube dass man dem
vierten heim bringen und dann der körper
sitzt denn die linzer im vergangenen
jahr habe ich gemerkt das war sie
sowieso viel schmerzen gehabt habe
habe lang im sommer viel zeit investiert
dass sie die schmerzen loswerden und
gott sei dank sind wir am super weg war
die sie so viel viel angenehmer zum
fahren und ja wenn es wenn es so läuft
denn dem vater gerne noch einige jahre
weiter
man sich auf den körper hören und so
lange vollgas geben kann und vorne
mitfahren bin ich sicher dabei aber wenn
das mal nicht mehr möglich ist dann muss
ja sagen danke das heißt da ohne
viel wehmut dann auch wieder auf den
körper hören und sagen können okay dass
das hierzu gewesen sein aber das war
schon angespart sein bruder hat sein
medizinstudium abgeschlossen ist jetzt
arzt in welche richtung wird das
dichtern verschlagen werden einmalige
momente kommen wird und wir hoffen
natürlich dass es so spät wie möglich
konnte was hast du dir alles so
vorgestellt für die zukunft habe es im
vergangenen herbst haben wir bei studium
abgeschlossen das nebenbei gemacht habe
das öffnet sich ja einige tiere in eine
spezielle richtung wirtschaft ich bin
aber nicht sicher wie im sport bleiben
möchte doch einige erfahrungen sammeln
können bis jetzt ja hier lass mich
überraschen das sind hoffentlich noch
einige aber bis dahin und wir werden
schauen wohin provinz betreibt was steht
in der nächsten saison an wenn jetzt
dieser mal abgeschlossen ist
wahrscheinlich einen längeren urlaub in
planung oder bis dann sofort wieder auf
sie sind in der vorbereitung für
nächstes jahr
gute frage ist würde jetzt ja urlaub
wird sicher kommen die veränderten einen
job anfangen die wird sicher nicht so
lange frei nehmen können nach dieser
saison zwei jahren klar interessieren
zum ewig wo weit weg fahren sondern
einfach mal ich hab wisselsheim bleiben
und dann nimmt im sommer mal lieber
pause eingeschlagen ja geht schon
richtung vorbereitung für die kommende
saison der trainer ist schon
viele neue ideen
ja da haben wir sicher wissen was vor
uns aber da ja wir haben ja gute basis
auf der man aufbauen können und
für die kommune ist es so wenn man sich
aber wieder einige ziele stecken setzen
wir aber dann verfolgen werden und die
einiges an motivation gab so wird die
eigene wahrnehmung von der
drucksituation sich verändern dass du
dann sagst du ich jetzt gehe ich als
olympiasieger der rhein in der nähe ist
es in die nächste saison in die nächsten
weltcups oder gibt es eigentlich mehr
lockerheit weil
das ausgezeichnet als bester ja die
auszeichnung ich habe viele sagen das
leben lang sowieso ganz realisiert habe
ich es noch nicht haben ich glaube es
nimmt man ja dazu kein handynetz letzten
saison als gesamt weltcupsieger 1
ich glaube
ein bisschen druckvoller
damals wirklich bei jedem rennen extrem
liefern und
gefühlter bisserl mehr und wenn man so
weit mit der led haben hat nimmt es sich
einiges an zu queren was möchtest du für
deinen sport noch alles schaffen ich
habe in meinen unterlagen verstehen dass
neben dem sport größer machen möchtest
vor allem das eigentlich immer
schwieriger ausrichter für weltcuprennen
zu finden also was möchtest du dann auch
mit verändern in seiner sportart die
natürlich jetzt in den letzten jahren
enorm gewachsen ist ja also wie gesagt
wir sind mit dem wachstum unsere
sportler gibt es nun nicht so lange also
das kann man jetzt nicht mit dem
skifahren vergleichen aber ich glaube es
ist sehr attraktiv auch für zuschauer
der die olympischen spiele haben sagt
wie spannend die ganze sache doch ich
bis zum schluss ja das war einfach der
weltcup tour etabliert die die gleichen
stationen fährt und dass die motive
bleiben und auch andere potenzielle
stationen fördert und motiviert zum zum
weltcups veranstalten und das geht
natürlich am besten indem man einen
heimsiege hat das heißt du gibst auf
jeden fall dann passt das alles gute für
die zukunft und gratuliere nochmal zu
diesem wahnsinnig tollen erfolg und
danke für deinen besuch vielen dank
ja das war es von uns vom sport bis zum
nächsten mal wir freuen uns auf euch
[Applaus]